La volta al món a peu, dia 278, sortint de Jorok, la ciutat que vaig estar descansant ahir.
Una ciutat més gran, més interessant del que m'esperava.
Tenen de tot, gairebé, entre cometes.
I són les 9 i pico del matí i començo a caminar.
Començo a caminar avui, dijous 3 de setembre, on oficialment podríem dir que comença el que jo crec que serà el tram més difícil fins ara de la volta al món a peu.
Segur que el tram més difícil de Tajikistan.
A veure, si tu mires el mapa, sembla que porti la meitat.
El que passa és que de Tajikistan hi ha una fina així, no? Bastantes giragonces.
I ara, a partir d'ara, el camí és més recte, cap a l'est.
No? Llavors porto, crec que uns 800 quilòmetres, 700 i pico, no ho sé, de Tajikistan.
I me'n queden 400 exactes.
Des d'aquí fins a Kulmapas, frontera amb la Xina.
I ara ve el tram dur.
El tram de les muntanyes del Pamir, de veritat, amb alçada i amb fred.
Vaig a explicar una mica el que ve a partir d'ara.
400 quilòmetres.
Surto des d'aquí, des de Kurob.
I segueixo caminant per aquí, per la Pamir Highway, la carretera del Pamir.
I aniré ascendent, ascendint, a poc a poc, fins als 3.000 metres.
En els propers tres dies, el que serà aquesta vall, seguiré.
Ja no estic a Quesnistan.
I, bueno, hi haurà pobles al costat, igual que més o menys com fins ara,
però cada cop una mica més de fred.
Un cop passats aquests tres dies, la Pamir Highway,
baixa una mica cap al sud-est i jo seguiré recte per una zona que anomenés de senderisme,
o, bueno, de bicicletes, o de 4x4, però no és la Pamir Highway.
I, bueno, veurem un llac molt maco i hi ha potser alguna petita població entre mig,
però hi ha bastant de menys cosa.
Després de tres dies o dos dies més, tornaré a enganxar amb la Pamir
i en aquest moment serà el tram que vindrà on no hi ha absolutament res,
fins a Murgab.
Espais oberts, molt de vent, zero surveys i fred.
Fins ara, a Tadjikistan, el que m'ha preocupat ha sigut la calor.
No parava de repetir-ho. Fa molta calor, m'estic torrant.
A partir d'ara, winter is coming,
i en alguns dies, segons la previsió del mapa, que això a vegades no l'encerta,
tindré mínimes de zero, menys dos o, menys i tot, menys quatre.
Ja veurem.
Ostres, Enric, ja tens un equip suficient per aguantar tant de fred?
Doncs, no sé si es veu que la motxilla està més plena.
He hagut de comprar algunes coses.
Us ho explicaré després, quan pugui trobar la motxilla i explicar-vos el que m'he comprat.
Crec que estaré bé. Però no us enganyaré, el que ve ara em posa nerviós.
Tinc una mica de... jo que tens una mica d'angoixa al pit, de nervis.
I que serà molt maco, també.
Però serà difícil. Serà difícil.
I a veure com ho porto.
La motxilla em pesa més per tot això que acabo de comprar.
I es nota. Es nota. Però estic satisfet amb la compra.
400 km.
Quant calculo que ho faré?
Doncs, jo calculo que entre 12 i 14 dies.
Alguns dies faré 30 i pico, alguns dies 40 i pico.
Després s'ha de comptar algun dia que potser no camino gaire, perquè...
estic algunagués, que us heu de descansar o el que sigui.
Jo crec que...
entre el 14, el 15, el 16 de setembre
hauria d'arribar a la frontera amb la Xina a culmapàs.
Que creuem els dits.
Però bé, avui sortim de Kurok. De moment, temperatura bona.
Màniga curta.
Trànsit, però tampoc gaire. Una mica d'ombra.
Let's go. Som-hi.
No...
Deixeu-me anar...
No faig res.
Vaig a enviar la gent.
No, jo no el coronito.
Primer, la ministra.
I la ministra...
A partir d'avui, ho faré.
Molt bé.
Doncs, doncs, a veure.
Deixeu-me anar.
Oh, oh.
Estem a poc de 40 dies, però...
Jo continuo.
Atenció, primera senyal de Kulma Pass, Kulma, recordeu aquest nom, la frontera amb Xina, el pas de Kulma, 394 quilòmetres.
Ui, em caic.
Buah, crec que serà molt emocionant quan el travessi, eh?
394 quilòmetres, bueno, a la introducció que he fet abans m'he oblidat de coses, sempre m'oblido d'algú.
El més important, el que m'estava preocupant els últims dos dies, que era el dolor als peus.
Doncs aquest matí, miraculosament, no tinc dolor.
Veurem si al llarg del dia, al final del dia, em tornen el dolor als peus, però de moment sembla que aquest dia de descans ha sigut molt profitós, no em fan mal els peus.
I segon, no només ascendirem fins als 3.000 metres, sinó que arribarà un moment que arribarem fins als 4.000,
i no serà puntualment, sinó que arribarem fins als 4.000 i ens mantindrem als 4.000 metres, per això el fred.
Però bueno, no ens preocupem per això, ara estic content.
Segueixo caminant, mira, per aquí.
Les dues i mitja.
Us en recordeu de la carretera pepiníssima per la qual vaig caminar fa dues setmanes?
No fa tant, eh?
No fa tant.
No fa tant, és que el temps passa d'una manera molt estranya.
Doncs bé, sembla que aquí n'hi ha una altra, també feta pels xinesos, o com a mínim això és el que sembla indicar el lletrero aquest, publicitari.
Doncs sí, una carretera de 3,5 quilòmetres només, amb ponts i túnels en aquesta vall.
Bueno, tu, doncs molt bé, parades de bus gegants.
No sé molt bé per què.
I aquesta verd, mireu, eh?
Mireu que verd.
Tu, molt bé.
Bueno, avui està sent un bon dia, porto força quilòmetres, no veig que arribi als 40, però bé.
Mira, encara tenen aquí la màquina de fer túnels.
És una estructura que aguanta molt de pes, llavors la posen i comencen a tirar ciment, bueno, formigó per sobre, ho tapen i quan ja està dur, doncs com té uns raïls, ho mouen uns metres i van avançant així.
I així van fent el túnel.
Aquest túnel no és un túnel d'escavar la roca, és un túnel que va al costat de la muntanya i el motiu és per, bueno, per evitar esgavissades, crec.
No sóc molt expert en túnels, diria que sí.
A Catalunya no en tenim d'aquest tipus, crec.
Mira, té fins i tot una barana i un passadís pels peatons.
Mira, trec el barret.
Està molt bé aquest túnel, eh?
Sí, sí.
I finestres.
Perquè ventili, ventili.
Bueno, mentre passo pel costat d'aquest riu de color turquesa tan maco, dir-vos que aquí estan les estadístiques de quan vaig fer 7.000 quilòmetres.
Que ja porto 7.200, però bé, no se les havia donat, aquestes són les estadístiques.
L'altra vegada que vam fer estadístiques, les nits de campada i d'hotel només comptava els dies que havia estat caminant, no?
Els dies de descans, no.
Però ara ja està comptat tot, és a dir...
En casa, en allotjament, o el que sigui, són total, també, dels dies de descans.
Perquè l'aventura és global, no només dels dies que descanso.
A més, a dia d'avui, que porto 7.211 quilòmetres, ja he fet un 27% dels quilòmetres totals que he de fer, que recordeu que són 26.232.
Per tant, porto més d'un quart.
He de fer...
Tot el que he fet fins ara...
Tres vegades més.
Una mica menys.
Bueno, alguns direu, ostres, Enric, ja portes bastant.
I altres direu, ostres, Enric, et queda moltíssim.
Bueno, són les dues coses, no?
Queda moltíssim.
Però, ostres, tu...
Déu-n'hi-do, ja porto un 27%, està molt bé.
Està molt bé.
Actualització, gairebé a les cinc de la tarda.
Brutal, eh?
El paisatge...
Increïble.
Ah!
Les muntanyes aquestes són...
I només ha d'anar més, això, eh?
Ha d'anar amb més muntanyes més altes
i paisatges més desobladors, encara.
L'aplicació Ioverlander
em diu que hi ha un lloc de campada bastant guai,
a 7 quilòmetres.
Sembla guai perquè està bastant amagat,
passa un petit rierol...
Podrà estar xulo.
Però igualment, aquí,
podria acampar en qualsevol lloc.
Per què?
En tot el dia no he vist cap militar.
Quina diferència
amb el que porto venint fent la setmana passada, eh?
Que veia militars constantment cada dia.
Clar, suposo que era el tema de la frontera amb l'Afganistan.
Avui cap, per tant...
On sigui, però bueno, aniré fins allà.
Mireu, està ple de camions, aquí.
Aquí, aquí, aquí.
Què vol dir?
Doncs que hi ha un restaurant.
Un bon restaurant, suposo.
És molt xulo, aquest restaurant, eh? Mira.
Mira, per desitjar-te,
aquest restaurant està com decorat, així...
Molt guai.
Ostres, si fos migdia, m'hi parava segur, eh?
Llàstima.
Mireu què té.
Wi-Fi amb Starlink.
Ojo, eh? Ojo.
Deu ser un Wi-Fi potent, eh? Perquè jo aquí tinc
dos raies de 4G, que no està malament.
Però, bueno, clar, suposo que els camioners
no tots tenen
targeta 5, no? Suposo.
Molt guai, bueno.
A veure si demà en trobo algun, no?, d'aquests.
Una mica de...
de Volta al món a peu de luxe.
Les instruccions eren claríssimes.
30 metres després del pont,
G a la dreta,
pel camí de terra,
i la primera clariana a la dreta.
Aquí ho tens. Sí, sí.
Molt el lloc, eh?
R a baixeta. Hi ha moltes
converíes.
M'agradaria pensar que no és
de campistes de l'aplicació Uberlanders,
sinó que és de locals.
Bueno, no passa res.
A mi no m'afecta. Jo em poso
per aquí i ja està bé.
Sento algun sorollet.
Espero que sigui de l'altra banda.
Oh! A més, no és tard, eh?
Està molt bé perquè no és tard. Tindré temps de
instal·lar els dos vents que
em falta per instal·lar. Fa un pèl de...
un pèl de vent. Vale.
Doncs ja ho tinc muntat.
Els quatre vents, ben tensos. Avui,
just ara,
quan acabo de plantar,
no fa gaire vent. Però bueno, era més muntar-ho
per... pel futur, no?
Perquè el dia que arribi el moment que
dic, buah, quin vent que fa, no hagi de
posar-me a muntar els vents aleshores, no?
Avui, segons el rellotge,
39,96
quilòmetres.
Ens hem quedat a
40 metres dels 40.
Bueno, al final sí. Llavors sí que els he fet, els 40.
No hi confiava, eh?
768 metres de
desnivell positiu. Però bueno, he fet una mica de pujada i
baixada. Però sí que és veritat que avui he
pujat des dels 2.000 sobre
l'aliment del mar fins als 2.500.
Demà, als
3.000. Encara vaig amb mania curta.
Per tant, encara
estic bé.
No fa molt de fred. Ok.
Està perfecte. I
res de diners m'he gastat 5 euros.
Avui no he parlat amb ningú.
No. Avui no.
I
cafès un i
refrescos tres.
Sí. Dos.
Bueno,
us ensenyo el que m'he comprat.
Tatxant
una altra genovesa.
Sí, sí, sí, sí.
Sí, sí.
Escolta, és de bona qualitat, eh?
Té la caputxa que pel vent va molt bé.
Abriga bastant. Té aquí
com... Veus? Com una mica de...
No sé.
Fel passats. I m'arriba
no fins al final del cul,
però tapo una mica del cul, que això és important
pel fred, també. I es veu
de bastanta qualitat, tenint
en compte que m'ha costat 35 euros.
La genovesa em va costar
27, recordem.
El color no és el meu,
però
està molt bé. La necessitaré.
A veure, jo recordo que
a l'hivern europeu hi havia dies que anava
tot el dia amb la genovesa.
Sí que és veritat que a l'hivern
el que passa és que les temperatures
diurnes també es mantenen baixes.
A l'estiu, bueno, encara estem
a l'estiu, el que passarà més aviat
serà que a les nits i pels
matins farà bastant de fred,
però durant el dia no crec que hagi de portar
això. No ho crec.
Llavors, per què m'ho he comprat? Sí, per la nit
estic dintre el sac. Bueno,
el meu sac està molt bé, però, si
no recordo malament, hi havia
nits que estava jo
a l'hivern passat
amb fred, feia fred,
i si no fos perquè vaig
dormir amb la jaqueta posada, potser hagués passat
fred. Bastant convençut
que sí. Especialment aquella nit
al Piemonte famosa de "-5".
Llavors, la posaré
per això, per estar en aquests moments d'acampament
que fa fred i pels matins, segurament.
No sé, potser no calgui,
però crec que és una cosa que
havia de comprar. Sí.
No sé. Pesa bastant,
però bueno, la portaré
si tot va bé, menys d'un mes.
I la segona cosa que m'he comprat
que m'ha costat molt de trobar,
molt, molt, molt de trobar,
és això, els guants.
Jo entenc que ara no és època, però
què fan quan s'acaba l'hivern
les botigues? Els cremen? No, doncs
hi havia una botiga que els tenia allà guardats en un calaix.
Igual que això. Igual que això.
Són uns guants
típics de...
de llana, però potser podrien ser-ho, eh?
Però són els típics guants gruixudets, eh?
Són bastant gruixudets,
cosa que m'agrada. No són per a vent,
però, bueno, són bastant
gruixudets, llavors jo crec que...
Sí. Sí, jo crec que
em serviran. El mateix,
potser no calen, però...
Els guants són més aviat, no tant
per quan fa fred que també, sinó per quan fa
vent i fred. El vent fred
les mans es destrueixen. No tenen tàctil,
però bueno, és igual.
Espero que
no en calguin, però bueno, jo crec que
en algun moment sí.
Llavors, eh...
ahir em vaig gastar entre
això, calçotets
i mitjons, que no cal que us ensenyi
que n'he comprat,
i algun dinar i alguna cosa que em vaig comprar
i em vaig gastar diria que 60 euros.
Sí, 35 d'això
i 25 de la resta, aproximadament.
Molt bé tu.
Mira, ja estic passant calor.
Eh...
Seguim ascendint,
seguim ascendint, i demà us dic
si em desperto
amb fred o no. Bona nit.